six years ago jordan peterson is warning
about bill c-16 he is warning that
governments are going to compel speech
meaning punish you if you don't use
speech if you don't use words and terms
that they want you to use so we you guys
know all about the big tech version of
this but now western governments are
doing this as well here is an incredible
story coming out of ireland ireland
we've got some info from the daily mail
a teacher who refused to use
gender-neutral pronouns for a
transgender student has been sent to
mount joy prison for contempt of court
enoch burke was arrested yesterday
morning for breaching a court order not
to teach at his westmeath school or be
physically present there after judge
michael quinn made his ruling mr burke
said it is insanity that i will be led
from this courtroom to a place of
incarceration but i will not give up my
christian beliefs
counsel for wilson's hospital schools
board of management said it was with a
heavy heart that it sought mr burke's
committal to prison but she said her
client had been left with no choice as
mr burke continued to attend the school
despite the court order which it had
obtained last week the dispute began
over his refusal to address a
transitioning student as they rather
than he as requested by the student and
their parents in may and agreed to by
the church of ireland school
this escalated to his suspension on the
day before the start of the autumn term
pending the outcome of a disciplinary
process he had refused to remain away
from the school on paid leave for that
suspension the court heard and would sit
in an empty classroom declaring that he
was there to work
okay so it is happening
it is happening where are the free
speech activists on the left where is
the aclu where are those good liberals
who should be screaming about it
screaming about this there is a man
in jail in ireland because he refused to
use someone's pronouns
and there will be people in jail in
canada because they refuse to do it and
guess what they will try to figure out a
way to do it here in the united states
thank god for that first amendment
although i have no doubt that the blue
states like cali and new york will
figure out ways to to trample on that uh
but what do we have to do what do we
have to do if we're here in the united
states well we really have to expose
this nonsense as it's coming i wanted to
show you a video that we showed you once
a couple months back uh this is senator
rand paul from kentucky
calling out uh dhs secretary alexander
mayorkas uh on his federal government
big tech disinformation board remember
this they were gonna have a
disinformation board uh which quickly
fell apart because enough of us fought
against it and then of course uh the
people who were in charge of the
disinformation board said that we were
sharing this information about them yada
yada but rand paul has been leading on
this that the government
should not have these organizations
because it in itself is an affront to
free speech how do you propose that
you're going to have an office of
disinformation governance
if you see the problem in even
determining what is disinformation oh
senator because
our work is not
focused on disinformation writ large
where we the department of homeland
security become involved
is when there's a connectivity between
disinformation
and threats
to the security of the homeland well
that's what the russians might be
considered that you mentioned the
russians the other day when you tried to
pivot away from this being about
censorship through social media and what
we do through us customs and border
protection
is actually communicate via social media
and other channels that that is false
that we do apply title 42. so let's say
there's russian disinformation as well
are you going to take to social media
and broadcast that people are
broadcasting something incorrect about
what do you think is russian
disinformation
senator let me emphasize you said the
other day russians and now you're saying
not so much the russians you're saying
the cartels no i'm not no i'm not
senator you're you're mischaracterizing
my state then what are you going to do
if there's russian disinformation you're
going to broadcast something on social
media
okay so do you see the package that
we're putting together here big tech
apparently doesn't want you
talking about personal responsibility
and understanding that it is your life
and you have some autonomy over it the
government seemingly doesn't want you to
be able to say what you think about
what's going on in politics they want to
be able to have boards of disinformation
thankfully this thing crumbled but they
want their word to be
the truth